cameras totally crooked still feel like
- I'm Ryan right and I'm Veronica
success nut Murray
so tonight I'm at Veronica's home and
we're in the garage right now lovely
we're gonna watch a Godzilla clip all
right yeah whoa
yes oh well and I'm in-between two women
this is awesome this is awesome it's a
good day for a Ryan so we're gonna watch
this clip a lot of you guys recommended
it it's called attack on Pacific Ocean
and hopefully it's good and if it isn't
I'm gonna blame all you guys okay not
the filmmakers you guys ain't that right
ladies you better watch out watch your
backs
you to feel like you two are my hit men
like you're badass chicas who work for
me like go kill that [ __ ] yeah
now I'm a Mexican gangster you do your
own heads right so I do my own pits yeah
I mean like you don't mind getting down
and dirty no make a lot of sexy or
something I'm like a little weirded out
it wasn't intended well it totally
sounded like yeah I just made Ryan
Wright uncomfortable I know this never
happens actually it's because you're
really pretty too so I look into your
eyes I'm always uncomfortable that's how
I work seriously don't look at submarine
I go with you why don't we have any
second already come on
hey Murr oh good I'd be sexier please
for my sake let's flex this glitter this
is my use is that the things he said to
me when I was younger she was a little
girl and I was the same age Oh some
shits about to go down
Wow
race why not nobody say to the bars
how creepy
you
ah
awesome
cause for pedestrians
what is it way to get a good sense of
how babies like how much an IMAX man
Friday that's the only way the only way
to watch a movie like that dude talk
about [ __ ] a sense of menace and fear
ain't that right ladies oh yeah oh yeah
yes they respond just the way I want it
that was actually really cool good but
it really has a tension there and it's
like saying hey we're actually gonna
scare you in this Godzilla movie and
they really know how to make him feel
like a monster without like saying here
look at crazy CGI they actually have
just pieces of him ain't that right
ladies yeah like I was here do they
really get a good sense of how big is so
enormous Lee grotesque is for those
skate those spikes are you sure your
scribing Godzilla this sounds a lot like
something else in my life it's seriously
unintentional but it's probably
subconscious so honestly when working
you say besides movies gonna rock and
check it out on Friday if you're new to
the channel subscribe please subscribe
isn't subscribing good for you huh yeah
it's good for your help it's good for
you yes we right yeah wait a participate
Murray I said yeah she said health and
you said heart doesn't health encompass
the heart well I got babies represent
like I was you said good for your health
and I'm saying like maybe it's not good
for like angry but it's good for really
like you more English like it's an
emotional and like also the cholesterol
oh it's good for you
cholesterol this must be what Charlie
Sheen felt like that one time alright
guys time for that part of the video
where you get mad at me for not saying
your name even though I constantly
explain their siliceous they are vicious
like vicious dogs a restaurant I used to
work in the hot dog places who ranted
and raved about that place it was the
best hot dogs in the world
if you're ever in California go there I
wish I would have had one before I
became a vegetarian
I've tried cooking with Ryan and he
insists on cooking everything the exact
same way he did Riley prime zero one
zero zero sky really wanted a shout-out
he actually sent me a Facebook message I
remember this guy now what's that Riley
Riley Riley it must feel good to be in
your prime zero one zero zero I bet he's
a robot that's the model number he is
yeah Riley prime zero one zero zero must
terminate we yeah what's up yeah
semicolon oh I get it
yeah funny guy I've seen that name so
many times and I'm like semicolon that
guy now see mini fallin my seaman's
calling me wants to come out right now
so semicolon wanted to shout out so here
you go I'll give you a semi shout out
shout out to set my call in Oh call is
for you that one's for you rocks is the
best I don't know if you're a girl or a
guy a lot of guys who sound like they're
girls based off their names are
apparently dudes I don't know you I'm
assuming you're a girl or roxas hasn't
made a video game name is it yeah I made
a video gaming that could be a fangirl
Oh fangirl what's up baby
how you doing hey you don't like
watching the channel huh yeah so shout
out but you wanna be one of the two
girls here what's going on ladies hmm
apparently I'm I'm part of the girls
mm-hmm anyway uh we're moving on yeah
thank you guys you have a good night
ciao